it is time for our final check of the
polls in 2019 we were away all of last
week it's been close to two weeks since
we looked at the polls and when you zoom
out the the real story to me is
basically bad news for Elizabeth Warren
let's take a look right now in an
average of recent polls
it is Biden in first place with 28
Bernie and second with 19 these are
averages in recent polls and Elizabeth
Warren in third place with 15 still
almost doubling Budaj edge who is in
fourth place with 8 now interestingly
and we're showing this to our video
audience I'll try to describe it to our
radio and podcast audience if you were
to draw a straight line across Joe
Biden's polling which is the Green Line
you will see that he is very close to
where he was in early July he's been up
he's been down since then but it's
basically an average of being in the
exact same place if you do the same with
Bernie's polling the light blue line you
see that he is roughly where he was in
early May but if you look at Elizabeth
Warren you see a much bigger upswing in
the earlier part of this year and a
pretty direct downfall starting with her
peak in the first week of October around
27% almost actually tied for first place
with Joe Biden down to where she is
today at 15 just barely
more than half of the support she once
had now if you look at the recent
individual polls that make up this
average you see that Joe Biden is right
around the low 30s with Bernie in the
mid to low 20s and Elizabeth Warren not
hitting 20% in any recent poll these are
of course national polls if you look at
the first primary states who will be
voting very soon we have Iowa where Pete
Budaj according to the latest polls
which are still not that new Pete Budaj
with a slight lead over Bernie Sanders
Bernie in second place in Iowa followed
by Joe Biden about a point and a half
behind then you look at New Hampshire
and you have Bernie Sanders in
first with Buddha judge just behind him
and Bernie and Biden rather further down
in third place so what's the trajectory
here what is next in 2020 the next
debate is on January 14th so far there
are only five candidates who have
qualified those are Joe Biden Bernie
Sanders Elizabeth Warren Pete Budaj edge
and Amy Klobuchar then and this is
really important we've been wondering is
the DNC going to change the rules to let
my Michael Bloomberg into the debates
Michael Bloomberg is a billionaire who
has been self funding his campaign and
not taking individual contributions he
very quickly was able to with the
expenditure of more than a hundred
million dollars in advertising get
himself five maybe six maybe even seven
percent in one recent poll which is
quite remarkable given how short of a
time it's been and it shows that at
least to some degree if you've got some
name recognition you can buy your way in
if you spend enough money into a primary
we wondered because Bloomberg is not
accepting donations and to get into the
debates you need to meet certain donor
thresholds would the DNC consider
changing the rules in order to allow
Michael Bloomberg in two debates
starting with the eighth debate in
February Tom Perez the DNC chair says
that they are looking at a different
system for determining who will be
allowed into the debates the idea that
he's using for cover is listen we have
had a system in place before anybody
voted once people start voting maybe we
should have a different system for
determining who does or doesn't get into
the debates now I've been saying for
weeks now they may do this and this is
how they figured out a way to maybe have
some cover in doing it our friend Dave
Weigel recently interviewed Tom Perez
and here's how the conversation went
yeah Dave Weigel asked Mike Bloomberg
said he's not going to raise donor money
if he runs he's going to self fund his
campaign which would prevent him from
accessing the stage under the DNC's
rules is there any chance that the
nc relaxes the donor requirement if
there's someone in the race who's
polling well or winning states but not
raising money and Tom Perez said we have
our rules in place for November and
December those rules have both the
grassroots fundraising threshold and a
polling threshold it used to be
either/or as you know Dave and now it's
and for November and December those are
the rules we haven't set the rules for
after the first of the new year and
that's something that we're doing right
now we always set the rules early enough
so that we can give notice to the
campaigns and Dave Weigel said so it's
possible it wouldn't be both it wouldn't
be an and anymore meaning both
fundraising and polling and Tom Perez
said we haven't figured it out one thing
we will consider is what should the
rules of engagement be after people have
started voting because right now zero
votes have been cast the voters haven't
spoken what should the rules be once the
voters have spoken and we have some
actual data from States that's the
question we're considering right now so
we now have with debate number eight in
February with the requirements needing
to be met in January the opportunity for
the DNC to change how they determine who
gets into the debates we're going to
keep talking about that because that
could be a big deal in terms of again
making the scenario one that ultimately
leads to an establishment centrist being
the nominee and we'll talk about that
more in the new year what if I told you
that you could read eight books in one
afternoon
that's essentially what one of my
favorite apps allows you to do it's
called blinka stand you can try it
totally free for a week and get 25% off
a subscription when you go to blink east
comm slash Pakman blink Asst takes
thousands of best-selling non-fiction
books gathers the most important info
and insights from each book presents
each book to you in the form of a
condensed ebook or audio book that you
can consume in just 15 minutes there are
only so many hours in your week blinka
stakes it possible for you to absorb the
most valuable takeaways from nonfiction
books that you otherwise might not have
a chance to read I just finished
listening to the way we eat now
by Bea Wilson whose work I've
recommended to you before super
interesting look at how the global food
system works and impacts the way that we
live you can use blink Asst to get
through a topic quickly and efficiently
it's really useful if you just want to
explore a certain topic but don't
necessarily want to commit to reading
the entire book about whatever it is and
a premium subscription is only about
eight bucks a month which gives you
unlimited access to every single book
that they offer they have books on
politics economics philosophy science
you name it
you can try it out yourself totally free
for a week and get 25% off if you decide
to subscribe just by going to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video